let's go
yeah i played last time i played b4 last
time against him i think
and i'll try it again
okay e5 bishop b2
f6 is a bit strange
a3 but yeah it might be entirely
possible because i just gave up my whole
center now
now i have to try to attack it by c4
bishop d6 i think i can go c4
c6 okay let's just play with
bit unorthodox i don't know i want to
give
okay let's go queen h5 check just force
g6
oh wow he doesn't play g6 okay
just moves his key i'm going to go
knight c3 here
it's playing like ultra position
looks on take this phone
it might be just worse here because the
knight d5 is
probably not a good move because i'm not
going to take back and
now my center is fine so
basically he just lost his right to
castle for nothing i think
28 now as his king is in the center i
don't want to trade so i come queen h4
i'm just going to develop normally
castle and at some point i'll break with
d4
g5 i can go quit a fix check so
that's not a problem yet castles
[Music]
still hard for me to play because d4 he
can take c3 and play
phone generally it's not so nice for me
to close the center i should be trying
to open up
the problem is that my queen is a bit
weirdly placed on h1
i would much rather have it on d1 okay
let's play d3
not lose on time
d3 root d1 just hoping that he loses
patience first
it's something like a there's actually
like a weird sicilian structure
finally you know
some sort of sham engine
it's the weirdest engine ever
okay i can play queen g3 because e4 his
bishop on d6 is hanging
now knight is a threat so
knight c3 bishop c3 okay yeah that's a
good move
i i never wanted to trade queens but i
think now i will just
i'll just do it it's fine
just a normal end game now i'll take the
two bishops
try to go e4 and d4 as soon as you get
the bishops you should
you should just open the center well
that's the general rule
so eb4 i think i'll take the bishop
try to open up further with e5
king on d6 is not so happy i guess
okay rook d1 qc7
let's go bishop e3 okay actually there's
a nice possibility
yeah this is nice kings here took c6
yes this importance mate
[Music]
this is called the borders mate
okay that sounds really good